hello everyone hope you're doing just as
well as I am doing fine today hope
everyone's doing just as well and I'm
just going to continue from where we
were yesterday or where we left off
yesterday and yesterday we were debating
at the last moment the difference
between logic and rationality and I'm
saying that there is a difference and
above all you know my focus is on my
focus on this is that you know you got
to be racist
you got to be you got to be in favor of
apartheid
you gotta distinguish between black and
white in science if if you allow these
Venn diagrams you know then get together
and you get all this gray stuff between
black and white that's what it becomes
very fuzzy and that's when people start
going in circles in their arguments so
language is important and the
definitions of words should be crisp
precise rigorous unambiguous it's when
you get this merging that you know this
confuses people because they use one
word and they you think it's for them in
their ears in their mind it's the same
thing as the other one and maybe to the
other person it's not and I want to
focus on these on this word logic and I
want to compare it against rationality I
don't like them to be synonyms I know
some people do I personally think they
should be kept separate and today I
looked at some of these definitions in
you know briefly and I do find that
there is a difference of perception of
what these words actually mean and so I
don't think you can in in other words
the status quo today is that these words
are not treated as fully being senator
that's the first part and I suggest that
if we're gonna introduce them into
science in a scientific context that you
absolutely do not treat them as synonyms
and one of the things that's gonna come
out out of this I hope because that's
what I saw and that's that these words
are not well-defined as of today words
like axiom words like logic rationality
these words are not you know keep
assumption these people you know they
have not really pinpointed these
definitions got a lot to do with the
fact that people have not learned very
well how to define words for the
purposes of science they don't
understand first the importance of the
finding them and second they don't do a
good job in defining them in a rigorous
manner so let me go with the with the
first word which is logic that's what I
found and it says I like the first sense
that I put up there and it's not the
first one in the Wikipedia but that's
the first one that I had wanted to put
up there so there is no universal
agreement as to the exact scope and
subject matter of logic that's a bad way
to kind of start your you know your
presentation it's like saying you know
we don't really knew what it is what it
means or what the scope of it is but
we're gonna use it anyways that's more
or less what they're saying there but
let's continue here says logic from the
Greek meaning the word or what is spoken
but coming to mean thought or a reason
so it means the word or what is spoken
and they mean by this thought or reason
okay and not not very good description
but after all it's just a word but what
comes next
are these statements that I pulled out
of there out of the wiki and it says a
subject concern with the most general
laws of truth and when people start
talking about truth I tremble now it's
truth you know fact very dangerous words
but look at the second most systematic
study of the form of valid inference
a valid inference is one where there is
a specific relation of logical support
between the assumptions of the inference
and its conclusion and again there's a
mouthful set there I'm not sure if I'm
gonna agree with all of that but okay
that's what it says and then the last
one says relation between ideas in other
words these are the notions people have
of the word logic and then in a separate
place I looked up in another place as
logic is the study of the forms of
reasoning in arguments and the
development of standards and criteria to
evaluate arguments okay so that's
essentially what the word logic means I
guess for most people these are the
notions people have in the back of their
minds when they use the word logic and
let me first put here the definition we
find in the dictionary this is in
dictionary that time you'll find this
definition there again there's three
criteria you could say the science that
investigates the principles governing
correct or reliable inference a
particular method of reasoning or
argumentation we were unable to follow
his logic that's an example right the
system or principles of reasoning
applicable to any branch of knowledge or
study and again that where knowledge
keeps popping up and again we never
defined it so it's a bad word to use
anywhere until people define it these
are the overall notions people have what
logic means to them and I want to
compare that with you know rationality
what do what do we mean by rationality
in comparison and again these are the
official versions out there and I like
the first one rationality is the quality
or state of being rational I love that
one it's just beautiful quality of state
rationality is rational okay that's good
that is being based on or agreeable to
reason so the quaint rationality with
reason or
pretty much make it so right rationality
implies that the conformity of one's
beliefs with one's reasons to believe
okay and of one's actions and with one's
reasons for actually essentially the
same thing
rationality has different specialized
meanings in philosophy economics
sociology psychology evolutionary
biology game theory and political
science in other words every discipline
has its own notion of what rationality
means and as you can see I don't know if
this was just an omission but physics is
not in there
neither is science and then we look up
okay so what do you mean by reason so we
look at reason is the capacity for
consciously making sense love that so
reason is making sense making senses
reason okay a reasonable reasoning or
whatever a making sense of things
establishing and verifying facts
applying logic but the word logic in
there and changing or justifying
practices institutions and beliefs based
on new or existing information reason or
an aspect of it is sometimes referred to
as rationality so we have rational and
reasonably but you can see that they're
not the well they do put the word logic
in there they did put that in there
momentarily but it's not very common to
see the word logic applied together with
rationality and reason conversely when
you look up logic they don't talk too
much about rationality or reason and you
know and so it's it's one of those
things that we even though people treat
them many times as synonyms it's not
like they are synonyms and when you look
up synonyms for rationality you don't
find a word logic that's so so
interesting in my opinion ever what one
gripe I have that's got talking over
there I'm got the one right by that with
criticizing these definitions that you
just kind of pull out of the Internet is
I mean I think it's correct when you
talk about them as notions they're not
really definitions in a strict sense
within a scientific sense of the word
they're not scientific can really only
criticize a one person this definition
is if someone's gonna give a
presentation okay so you see the person
or your you're just one person talking
and that guy gives the definition now
you can criticize the president I've
finished me it's there's kind of no
point in criticizing definitions pulled
out of these main areas of the of the
internet like the Wikipedia or some
random forum or whatever well let me
answer that I asked someone for his
definition and he gives me this
definition what should i do then
criticism okay that's the first one the
second one is that you know a lot of
people will say well you know let me
look it up and they'll go and now go to
the Wikipedia or the dictionary and
they'll say well this is what I found
yeah they get up you're [ __ ]
yeah I mean you're coming to your doing
here your homework in front of the
teacher you can't do that yeah do your
homework at home and then come yeah and
that's the point the point is that's a
different point my point is there's no
point
criticizing no but there's an original
definition there's another issue you're
rich people yeah there's another issue
here and the issue is that you know
whether the Wikipedia were that the
dictionary get these notions they gotten
from you know from from the worldly
wisdom in other words that's what how
people have essentially used the words
over the centuries and and so that's
what they mean yeah I'm not sure I'm not
sure you can deviate too much from what
I just read from the wiki I'm from the
dictionary if you ask any person on the
street know what is logic they might say
well I think they'll give you a notion
similar to yeah yeah but that's my point
you know you're kind of but but the the
the the degree at which you're kind of
nitpicking about these definitions is
almost as is that level of nitpicking
really only applies to someone specific
scientific definition yeah you can't
really nitpick know these are really
notions I mean when you go to dictionary
calm all you're gonna get our notion
yeah correct you know you're never gonna
get a scientific definition right you're
not gonna get the scientific definition
but this gives you another
notion and that's that you know even the
dictionary and many times I think the
Wikipedia does that as well they'll say
oh but for the purposes of physics for
the purposes of math for the purposes of
biology so they say you know in this
discipline this is what this word means
you know they'll go through all that and
that's another thing to keep in mind
because if after 10,000 years they still
don't have a precise definition of logic
one that is scientific that you can
include in an encyclopedia I couldn't
find the word some of these words I
couldn't find them in in the Stanford
encyclopedia of philosophy would you
messed up already by saying they don't
have a definition they never have a
definition that's my point
there's no such thing as they have they
have notion none has a group of people
only one person can have a definition
that's my that's my criticism yeah but
you would talk about definitions you're
talking about one person you're talking
about then as soon as you bring up two
or more people now it's a notion well no
no no because because if if you go to
the I don't know two given discipline
archaeology I don't know and you say
well what does this word mean and that's
what the the whole you know conference
agreed upon and that's that hold it and
this is the word how it's used in their
discipline then you know with minor
tweaks here and there
see you say it yourself
when someone comes to a presentation
they can find their words yeah for the
purposes of their presentation not for
the purposes of various presentations
Hereafter okay but it's not it's not a
Greenup but I need I need to have
something to attack in other words I can
how many brothers people cannot avoid
defining these terms and if these other
the way they're defined I'm gonna attack
the official definition now there's some
other definition out there well I'll
wait till by you know I cross that road
but right now I'm attacking what these
people are putting on there and I'm sure
the people who work on Wikipedia are a
lot of them you are into philosophy and
so on and they'd understudy and you know
I haven't gone through there to find out
who's who but what I'm saying is you
know the
by now they have reached more or less a
consensus of what that word means I'm
gonna attack the definition I see if
there's another definitional and front
bridge when I get that consensus thing
is just kind of what I'm focusing on
you should never criticize a group
definition because again I'll say it
again anytime you're talking about two
or more people you're talking about a
notion it's a Venn diagram now because I
mean a good example of this is the word
life they always say we never come to
consensus on the word life why because
everybody has their own use of the word
now so you can't really criticize if you
type in life in dictionary calm no point
nitpicking about it because it's not one
person's definition yeah but one person
comes and gives a presentation on he
gives a specific definition scientific
definition then you can nitpick it all
you want yeah and all I can say is right
now I'm gonna attack just the official
version this is the official version
that's the one a lot most people
probably out there I'm gonna read back
to me
I'm just gonna attack this one I don't
care if there's another definition out
there fine I'll cross that bridge when I
get with that I think using the word
definition is incorrect I'd call them
notions well no this is a definition you
get quoted it's a definition as far as
the dictionary is concerned if this is
the definition that's the one I'm gonna
sing the word definition incorrectly
fine I have to have something to attack
and I'm gonna be attacking the
definition I find a dictionary now if
someone has a better definition
bring it on you know I'm willing to
listen to it you know right now I'm just
gonna attack what I see out there what I
saw in the wiki what I see in the
dictionary what I saw in the Stanford in
the Stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
that's what I'm gonna attack because
that's to me essentially what the
worldly wisdom is out there maybe
they're not precise maybe they don't
have you know very scientific fine but
that's that's all I can attack right now
but that's a good that makes a good
point maybe huh the word definition
should be reserved for science
everything else really notions okay that
I can deal with you and I think that's
that's pretty much on the money too
yeah we can say that for the purposes of
ordinary speech you know common language
out of the street line then we can call
you know shiny people have these vague
notions of what these words mean they
don't you know they say love movies
Mountain what do you mean love moves
here that says poetry and that's how we
use it you know so you know it's uh it's
not precise language but you know he's
right if we're gonna bring it into
science and we can call it a definition
and say look now we were gonna use
precise language to define this word and
in that sense he is right and and that's
maybe to some degree very important what
unsaid there because it means that you
know if we're gonna define the critical
words that we're gonna use in science we
don't have to define every word in the
dictionary for the purposes of science
because most of them are not necessary
but then you know maybe we should only
refer to those words which are
scientific as definitions and not to
what we find in the dictionary we can
say those are not definition even though
that's the word we used to refer to them
maybe the correct word is notion there's
a vague notion of what this would mean
this is in general terms here it is but
if you're gonna bring in the science now
we're going to talk about definition and
now we're gonna be very precise in our
language to define that term because
otherwise it causes a monster you know
it's a if you don't define that word
precisely people different people
understand different things now we can
talk about definition of precise
rigorous definition yeah you're right I
like that you know that's a good point
another way to look at it is going back
to the computer a computer understands
the definition but a computer doesn't
understand a notion right that's very
good that's that's good definition you
just give it these criteria it follows
those criteria no chance like well you
kind of know what I mean
when I say love we all kind of know what
we mean if I if I read a computer
stationary if I type in love at
dictionary.com all kind of agree with a
problem whatever it says over yeah yeah
Peter you gotta feed it laughs you put
that in the computer now it's gonna
throw if it'll spit out something there
are many scenarios that you can spit out
the you'll be like wait that's not love
or you know it'll be kind of weird
you know that's a good point maybe the
way we should test definitions with
computers there's no ambiguity there you
define it and now you're gonna use and
when you use it in it and then the
computer rejects it or doesn't know what
to do because it it has you know you
applied it wrong and the computer said I
won't let you do that then you'll know
what a definition is because now your
life depends on whether you gave it one
difficult one criteria too many or one
criteria to view and then many then
there's a conceivable example like the
one you give with it's white and it has
wings yeah you got either a swan or the
white house yeah you're either missing a
criteria you have one too many killed in
a bird or whatever Peter will give you
back both until you say it's an animal
now okay now the white house maybe
depends on who's in the White House
anyways so so where does this lead us
well all I can do again is compare what
I find out there with what I'm proposing
and and again here you have this notion
of what rationality is let's see if I
can fit mine up there as well for
comparison I want you to see how
different how they defined it you know
let's see if I put it a little higher
it's a rationality the quality of state
of being rational reason the capacity
for conscious ly making sense and all
that's vague and I'm gonna book writing
to show you the contrast so what I'm
referring to when I say you know
rational or whatever here it is you want
to put down here let's see if I can can
ask a quick question
no defying I mean can we get a verb for
a notion like you know shinned oh let's
think about that for a minute here here
I'm giving you criteria for what I call
irrationality and I'm concerned about
irrationality but you can put this in
reword this in a way that you can say
what is rationality and the first one
that you don't convert a concept into an
object and then pretend to move it
around at least for the purposes of
physics you can see where that's going
to lead into problems and so I'm giving
you a specific criterion here that you
can take to the bank because you can say
okay I understand what you're saying you
can't turn love into heart and begin to
move the heart around you can't turn
location into point or number into point
and then begin to move the point around
you know the point is that dot you can
move it around but you can't move
location around and things of this
nature second one now you can't use
undefined words or words that you use
inconsistently third one theory doesn't
file from the from the assumptions that
the explanation doesn't follow from the
hypothesis these are all criteria and
and I want you to see these are pretty
much objective in the sense that you can
sink your teeth into these you can say
okay now I know what rationality means
at least for the purposes of physics you
know I can't convert a concept into an
object you can see that that's different
than what these people are saying for
how they define the word they say the
quality or state of being rational
agreeable to reason what does that mean
you know and then you look up a reason
of the capacity for making sense and so
on and you know it's like it's all very
vague you don't have it but mine are
very concise that you want to know what
irrational is you turn a concept into an
object that's the Rasch I like that
because you know and now you you can
sink your teeth into this besides using
the word criteria it's kind of like
giving an example in a way yeah it's
like it's like turning a concept into an
object that's an example I mean it's
kind of like a meta example it's an
umbrella where you example like this
exactly turning boat like the one you
gave love into a heart yeah and moving
the heart around that's an example of
this meta example where you go obviously
and you know any example you can come up
with or you turn a concept into an
object is irrational by your definition
correct well there's kind of doesn't
give you this umbrella meta example or
you can come to the grain store that's
the thing it's too big it doesn't give
any
criteria or like borders for examples
yeah let's look at let's look at an
example for there's let's see if we can
come up with an example let's see if I
didn't think about that we should have
done that I should have done I mean you
should have done that okay
ration quality or state of being
rational or let's go agreeable to reason
okay agreeable to reason is the notion
of what of rationality and then they go
into reason and they say the the
capacity of making sense of things you
know what does it mean dude did you make
sense I don't I don't think you made
sense but the guy thinks he made sense
so so know we get into this argument no
no I made sense I know you didn't make
sense and you know this is the problem I
see you there's no Crichton I can't
what example can I come up with making
sense you know well one thing about
theirs is theirs is by definition or by
logic is subjective that's I think your
little sense but you don't think you're
making sense or you think you're making
sense objective while yours is by
criteria the robot the robot I
understand understands the instructions
well now I'm but by buying their
definition or whoever's definition to
put that up yeah my their notion I like
the word notion more in this sense by
that notion or if we took it let's
actually use the loop of wrap of a
scientific definition let's call that
their scientific definition yeah okay
but if we were going to consider that as
the same thing how would you program it
yeah because now it's who are you asking
who make by show of hands who thinks
that he made sense no I'm
imagine if imagine if I put these
definitions in a computer right we're
gonna program the computer more gonna
have the computer tell you whether you
are rational irrational or reasonable
right and so you say okay agreeable to
reason and the computer says okay I got
that one now what is reason making sense
okay I got that once and then anything
right by who's right and so now you say
something to be
you're not making sense you know and he
said what do you mean up not me I'm
Russian oh no you're not rational and
you know I mean what are you gonna use
here you've got nothing this is all so
vague there's no black and white
there's no you're right there's no set I
think that's the good thing about
criterion program they call it a boolean
it's either it's either on or off yes or
no 1 or 0 it's it's either right it's
either red or it isn't it's either black
or white like the way it's either five
meters tall
it's either over five meters or five
meters and under there's just like this
on/off thing while if you say agreeable
to reason whose reason yeah which Kryten
what criteria do we apply for reason
that's the lesson there's questions but
the problem with with making sense that
phrase it goes back to the it's in the
offensive or proof category where it's
like proof to whom offensive to whom
make reasonable to whom right listen the
to whom category where it's like all
these phrases kind of fall under who you
ask
Wow concise yeah or or white I mean I
mean that could be colorblind or or
whatever but if we're just talking about
frequency or whatever but in fact colors
you can't oppose you can't say black is
the opposite of white no no I use that
phrase but it's not right like if you
say it's red or not red yeah 620
nanometers wavelength or not we could do
that to the computer you could program
and say look I'm gonna be fine red at
620 nanometers right or 6280 or whatever
and so if you've got 621 or you got 619
it's not read according to the computer
it doesn't like all these fuzziness
unless you guys fine or not unless you
unless you give it a range right but if
you just program in there 620 then you
then the computer will easily analyze
that say this is red this is not periods
it's black or white red or not red but
in this case but but see you got a if
you're gonna talk scientifically if
you're gonna talk consistently or use
these terms
a consistent manner you have to define
it like that you have to give the
computer some objective criteria then
the computer can tell you you're
rational or irrational your theory is
rational yours is not you know that kind
of thing actually it's a good point
about the to whom category like the to
whom category because is this category
of phrases ideas and words that are left
oak that they are read for some people
not read for others you know what I mean
whereas think for example let's take the
word tall okay Joe thinks he's tall
Sally thinks he isn't tall [ __ ] when
we're tall is is it to whom while five
meters isn't it's like an objective
thing that their their objective it
can't go this kind of well tall is a
comparative work but that's the thing
comparative is is proof is offensive
offensive compared to non offensive
proof wouldn't mean offensive words
where it's like it depends on who you
ask
that's that's the that's the category
but we usually buy offensive like like
if someone says when you say something
and someone says that's offensive
oh how you got asphalt to whom to whom
is it offensive
so you million you'll never offend a
professional comedian he's heard it all
well if you take a church girl she'll be
offended by everything almost you know
that kind of thing or say the same thing
applies to tall or if you got a really
tall guy already he's two meters tall
tall they'll probably have way less
thing he'll call way less things taller
than a [ __ ] yeah they'll probably call
more things tall but just because it's a
to whom it's a relation depends on who
you ask same thing was proof some people
are proved to the God exist some people
aren't proved they got it relationship
depends on who you ask
like what was proof some people compare
to remeasure comparison a goddess or
starter 20 angstroms
right now let's see if it works now
I'm trying to find out is this all there
it did fixed it yeah we just turned off
so I had I had youtube on but the sound
was turned off yeah we have all kinds of
wrong with Sam I still don't understand
how we have so many sound prongs we
always have the same set up with new
problems there okay can you hear me okay
right now now we're back to normal okay
we are then I just turned this off
that's what it is yeah we might have to
you might have to take the video cut
that part out so that people don't get a
headache and then yeah okay Mike
okay so what just the last ten minutes
maybe and before that it was an irony
take this yeah I don't get it we always
have different problems you know we
always have the same setup okay so where
were we
let's go back let's go let's backtrack
on viewers we're saying about the the
precise definitions of words such as
rationality and and
logic and I'm saying you know let's
let's go over that material one more
time just in case here we have the
definition of logic the science that
investigates principles governing
correct or reliable inference and again
here you're saying reliable and reliable
according to whom you know I mean all
these are subjective that means they all
require things or they all require an
observer to tell you what is rational
what is reasonable when it'll be liable
you need a referee yeah you need a
referee yeah yeah and they're subjective
and in in this case and you know in my
definition when I'm proposing for
rationality and why I see it is it's
very different you can see that you know
if you convert a a concept into an
object that's a you know straightforward
criteria criterion maybe that's a thing
maybe we're talking about subjective
criteria versus object a great clarity
or subjective criteria the way to figure
out if it's a subjective criteria you
have to you have to but ask the question
to whom or for whom right right right
who are you asking because that's what
integrity implies yeah while objective
criteria is regardless of who you ask
it has it basically is or isn't
regardless of who you ask
that's I guess that's the objective one
where if for example will you said yeah
turning in concept into an object yeah
although it's hard to tell if
something's subjective or objective
because turning a concept into an object
now Sally might sound well in this case
you are turning a concept known object
but she just might be mistaken
yeah but again you can't when you use a
criterion just such as turning a concept
into an object it's a it's an objective
criterion again
Sally comes and says oh but in this case
you know she might be mistaken for
example yeah you might say oh but here
you turn the concept into an object even
though you didn't you know it's like who
is to say that you did it or didn't it
who is to say that you didn't turn the
concept into an object or that you did
can turn a concept into an object so you
really don't need you don't need a
referee because all you got to do is
look up word and in other words we have
definitions for what an object is what a
concept is is if an object is that which
has shape then okay anything that has
shape is an object if it doesn't have
shape
it's a concept and you can't say you
know you can't say that you turn
something which does not have shape into
something that does have shape that's
and so it's in essence objective it's
like you know and you look upwards and
now there are problems someone still
have to figure out if we're talking
about shape or not if the thing has
shape or not why would we need to debate
that both relate it but someone has to
has to discern down the line to know if
something's irrational right yeah you
have to know if you're turning a concept
into an object ya know that you have to
know what an object is yeah you know
where an object is you have to you
define it as gotta go down the line
right well again all I'm saying is once
you define what an object is and let's
just put that as a black of watches for
the sake of discussion right here you
can say look an object is that which has
shape concept is that which doesn't
that's not the definition but that's
what we'll use right now right and so
you take any word you say okay distance
and you say well you know that doesn't
have shape distance per se doesn't have
shape okay you say intelligence well you
know you cannot imagine a shape for it
so you can go on different words in and
so now the person says well I'm gonna
move distance or I'm gonna move
intelligence or I'm gonna do grace and
that's where the periphery automatically
the computer
computer did you feed these were
computers a different computer and
referee and I think the word referee in
this context is not objected oh no no no
I think the word referee should really
just be reserved for a subjective
criteria because if you Paul that's all
we should use the word referee unless
unless unless you know you know you had
the instant replay and football computer
right right but he's a referee if you
have a referee yeah you got him someone
on their side no no yeah but Hoda hold
it you have a judge of referee or
whatever you want to call the guy who's
you know in in the field right or in the
boxing place right but then you know you
say okay let's look at the instant
replay why do we go there because that's
subjective
they say you can't cheat the other
machine you know example if this is the
difference between a really nice
presentation about the difference
between sports and games video games
where they say in sports you have rules
whereas in games you have laws like
physical laws in a sport games in
soaring that okay it's my sports more
what's with their weapon yeah there's a
difference okay I mean the rules in
sports and the laws in a video game in a
competitive video game in soccer for
example okay I think I know where you're
going in soccer you you're not allowed
to pick up the ball with your hands but
your hand
we just agreed not to while in the video
game is physically in Palermo there's no
way to make the character pick up the
ball with the hands because it's not
programmed in yes it's not program so no
matter how you try the rules are more
like laws you can't even do them no
matter how hard you try wall okay
laws of God and yes along here are there
really a fix it's it's gonna impossible
that's kind of the difference we're in
in sport it's kind of like okay we have
rules and now we need a referee to make
sure you're following the rules or so be
kind of just kind of eyeballs it there's
no there's no way to like god there's no
way to objectively know if everyone's
following the rules your example of the
computer I think is great because I mean
imagine applying that the science or to
the mathematicians you know they say
well you know that's your opinion okay
look let's go to the computer let's
program the computer any you program it
any way you want okay and let's see if
you can use your definition consistently
and and the computer will boot them out
whereas I can put these definitions my
definitions in there in the computer and
it'll treat them perfectly well because
they're objective there their objective
criteria they don't depend on your you
know on your opinion all you have to do
is like if you're gonna distinguish
between objects and concepts and say
well you know you can't turn a concept
into an object fine what do we mean by
that well let's let's feed the computer
all the concepts let's feed the computer
all the objects say this is not this
offensive this is an object this is a
concept right so now you feed it in
there now the guy can't escape now he
can fight outside the computer before we
punch the words in there right he can
say well let's debate this one is is a
hologram with an object or a conch okay
let's fight it out let's go to the ring
let's fight it out fine well once you
miss that once you put it in the
computer there's no way out of it you
know and this is the issue the issue is
that you know all these things have to
be that would be the way to determine
what is rational what is not the
computer will tell you that that's why I
like computers they're they're not
rational they're logical they just
follow whatever instructions you give
them okay gonna be the doll you make up
now you made me think of that and that
word logical it's the dumbest
instructions in the world but they'll
follow the instructions to a tee the
instructions have no application for
science application for anything okay
but it's following the truck it's
basically instructions that's all logic
you put it you put a new element into my
head now I got a look at that you just
say you use the word logical you applied
in the context of computers and we're
applying it into the in the context of
words not in math but in words you're
saying look you're gonna put the word
love in there or energy concept you're
gonna put the word dog that we retrieve
that's gonna be an object fine so now
you got all that stuff now the computer
just follows the logic all right I like
a good good replacement word for lodging
isn't struck
inally because instructions is it's kind
of like shape for object logic is
basically just instructions it's a
better word for logic it's instructions
with instructions
it could be instructions that lead you
to nowhere but you can put there
instructions that can be followed you
can follow the instructions following
the logic is is tantamount to following
instructions because that's what you do
while doing the rules of how to reason
no nobody earthly instruction following
some some rules here
the computer is just saying look I'm
gonna follow the rules that you
programmed in here right so it's
following the rules of wood what are we
saying it does lose of logic but that's
why I like the word instructions more
than rules because destructions is
basically a B a goes to B goes to C goes
to D do this then that and that and that
if this then go here instead of there
and it's just a basic basic let me put
something up here let me put something
up real quick because it's just
pertinent to what you just said here's
the what you will see this is the
typical logic okay that we find out
there if a then B okay therefore a or a
therefore B okay that's the way it is so
if a then B a therefore B okay it's very
clear and that's that's the recipe for
logic and what you're saying is let's
put this in the computer now okay yeah
it is that's what it is it's in and
that's what I'm getting at that's why I
put it up there yeah well what we're
doing here we're saying look this is
this is how these are the rules and we
programmed this into the computer we say
okay the computer is going to follow
these rules a a 1 2 & 3 if a then B
number 2 a 3 therefore B okay it's just
a standard logic or the more most you
could say the most basic logic there is
and that's essentially what you're doing
with a computer the computer you say
okay when
program it that anything that has shape
is an object anything that doesn't have
shape is a concept you define that first
then you can put the all the words in
the dictionary in one place on the other
fine and now and now you just press the
button you know and you say well hey is
therefore good that right Polly is going
this way all the bees know that all the
things that are object over here
categorized in objects although or
better say all the things that have
shape you know go in this category all
the things that don't have shame go in
that kind of the robot or the program
knows how to separate them right David
instructions the right criteria yeah not
subjective criteria you don't have to
ask anybody there's no opinions here
it's not it's not things that are tall
the computer will never understand
things that are tall to life you
actually say above five meters below
fight me right now you know some some
definite right period
it's like we said before you give it 620
nanometers that's read for for the
computer anything that's not 620 it is
its ground read yeah and I guess the
point here the point that I'm trying to
make here is that now you have a way of
debunking a lot of mathematicians into
forums or wherever when you get into
debate with someone tell them that okay
you're saying this this and that okay
let's put it in the computer what do you
think the computer would spit out and
let him see his own the error of his
ways by by that method by you know the
computer's objective and you say okay
how would you program the computer what
would you put in there for the word for
example the word object right
some people say what's mass others say
its volume it's that which moves okay
they've got all these things so so we
have a rock well the rock doesn't move
but that's the thing I got to move it
and I'll get well what do you and I do
only play devil's advocate uh-huh not
just for it that will get for fun but
well we actually play devil's advocate
that's what we fight and if any time we
come up with a theory what you're trying
to do with that theory is tear it down
to make sure that it holds water right
so when you come up with something yours
taking the role of the worst case
scenario of the robot what's the worst
that was the dumbest thing the robot
could come up with that would shatter in
your definition right so come on take it
to extreme for example they say what was
these happily you said that which has
volume right for exact that was you can
see in touch let's take that one
the robot can give you something a space
space now can you see or touch space M
no can you see your time not on that
black hole no like okay now or or even
better just a star we can't that's in
the distant galaxy no one's ever seen or
touched right now the computer is gonna
be a well-known scene or touch this so
this is an object yeah until you do it
until you run the experiment and tell me
that you can touch the Sun and you can
see it then yes yeah we're talking about
something on the other side of the world
unless you unless which we talked about
thing in the very first video where you
give the star that no one's seen or
touched you give it the parameter
seeable or touchable but at that point
you might as well just say this is a
knob you might as well define it as as
an object but then that's kind of
cheating it's like saying okay we're
gonna called black holes object you just
program the computer to know that
whenever you use the word black hole it
put it in the object category without
any definitions or parameters you just
tell it to put it there yeah I got a
life force I got a better one you know
you put the blind man to do the computer
and now you can't see or touch it yeah I
can't see or touch the moon so the moon
is not a knob you get you can cheat with
the robot in the sense of if I just say
instead of giving you parameters to
organize it itself yeah you just kind of
cheat and say look computer black hole
is an object okay don't ask any question
write a different issue that's what I
mean with seeing touch where you say
well yeah no one's seen or touched the
the star of the distant galaxy but it is
seeable or touchable yeah but but they
don't know that that's right yeah how do
you know that's kind of that's that's
just circumventing the problem that's
just kind of cheating you might as well
say that is an object because I say it
is but you can also say I can
potentially see or touch love and now
the computer said oh yeah okay you say
so yeah yeah I can see your touch love
or energy to get away with it we'll
still somewhere down the line of what's
going on and then you'll find out like
for some chain of logic it goes like
okay like in the short term you don't
notice it or there's no difference but
then somewhere down the line this small
detail makes a big difference later on
down the line yeah there you go and then
it turns everything down in here like
why is the program acting up and it's
because he was put it into the law but
again all I'm saying here you have a
little recipe for debating this little
trick that you can say to anyone who is
challenging you or whom you challenge
he's okay put in a computer make you
make this class I like lakum like
martial arts like self-defense you know
one of the things I put in my website is
that I'm trying to provide tools for
rational people out there to beat up on
the mathematician so that's like martial
arts you send yourself I'm sorry dojo I
like to do that I like to give tools to
people so that they can you know people
go into the forums they get trashed many
times and this is a good way to give you
a tool to say okay you know I'll go like
mr. nice guy in there and maybe act as a
silent devil's advocate you know and say
well you know how about this and how
about that and what if we put into
computer what would it spit out and let
the guy think for himself and see what
kind of conclusions he reaches maybe he
finally sees himself in the mirror for
what he is you know and all this is good
way to establish who's rational who is
not these martial arts tool is also a
good way to figure out a few yourself or
rationally or you're not the good thing
about doing this with yourself is
there's no ego really involved when
you're just trying to figure out oh yeah
I'll kick that computer nice talking to
yourself right and you take these things
you can defeat the irrational part of
yourself but with that what it's about
it's a different way of seeing yeah yeah
what do you do when you're trying to
reason things out you're essentially
playing both sides you're arguing with
yourself yeah and if you have these
tools you can kind of defeat the
irrational part of your brain that takes
you off on tangents yeah yeah yeah it's
it's a good way of testing your sub or
your own logic or whatever but you know
what I hate you what you did today you
you put a little put a piece of poison
in me you know with that thing about
logic you know the computer works with
logic I wouldn't say a computer is
rational yeah you know so now you use
that word logic and now under that
context you opened up a can of worms
inside my head I got to go out there see
I was gonna talk about axioms and so on
I think I'm gonna keep my mouth shut
now I'll just say the following
and with this we and let me say the
following here's uh is this the one
[Music]
where is it somewhere in here I had it
yeah let's please they have pauses every
now and then it has like give give
people time to reflect on all we said we
know I've had something for oh here it
is here's here's the word axiom okay and
it says an axiom or postulate is a
statement that is taken to be true okay
right sound problem in your sound
problem is there any way that says axiom
or postulate a statement that is taken
to be true and again this is what we
were talking about yesterday with Shamu
you know what he came on it's a it's a
statement taken to be true in other
words it's not an assumption and let me
clarify that assumption means is it's on
the bottom something taken
for granted this one is something taken
to be true there's a difference between
taken for granted and taken to be true
well a grant that means that momentarily
you're gonna concede because you're just
trying to understand what the guy what
the guy's theory is what he's trying to
say so you okay let's concede that let's
assume that yeah I like taken for
granted in a different way or site I use
taken for granted
my assumptions that you don't even
mention the implicit assumptions like
like when you give a theory of the guy
getting shot in the head and in your
theory you you don't explicitly invoke
gravity but implicitly you're talking
about the real world which has gravity
and that's the taken for granted
well all I can do is clarify for you
because this is where I had a problem
yesterday and and again I got to go back
to the drawing board after which a
difference between an assumption and a
yeah I'm saying I'm saying the
difference is that an axiom is perfectly
true
it's in fact let's put it up there again
because it's a it says it there it's a
statement that is taken to be true to
serve as a premise or starting point for
further reasoning an argument that's the
way I always imagined their whole day
let me finish the work the Doyle can't
care about where it comes from and says
hey self-evident truth that requires no
proof self-evident proof yeah it's like
axiom you you cannot challenge it okay
axiom is the damn truth it comes from
God okay action is truth whereas an
assumption is a little different yeah
quite a significantly different
assumption says look please accept my
soup position when I'm gonna say next as
truth for the moment only for them on
just concede it so that you can
understand my theory and so the guy says
okay let us assume blah blah blah blah
blah and now the guys say okay I'll
assume that I'll concede that just for
the sake of argument and that's
different than saying an axiom which is
absolutely true in you I'm not asking
you to
leaving it I'm saying you better believe
it I force it down your throat yes
that's the difference is the difference
between axioms and assumptions going by
will you just say yeah kind of something
like axioms are verifiable while
assumptions you just kind of verify oh
yeah like like like and maybe there's
two kind of like the humorous yeah but
the right kind of like that but there's
there's two things involved there the
first one it's already been verified
yeah yeah and the second one is you can
verify it if you want prove it to
yourself you know that great you know
like the pen falls to the south you know
where it is you know like that salvation
when we're talking about the word
knowledge right we hit a nice kind of
like kaverin like kind of war attention
to it this is a really nice tangent just
really big can of worms and we talked
about I just lost it something about
knowledge stare on our nose when we're
talking about knowledge when we're
talking about oh yeah patterns uh-huh an
axiom is under the category of pattern
where how to recognition there's no such
thing as as in like did Johnny go to the
store yesterday that can never be an
axiom because that's not a pattern
that's not a repeatable thing like
Halley's Comet okay Halley's Comet is is
is this theater program that is more
like an axiom because it's a thing that
keeps happening in that sense it you can
do it yourself at home
like that like the 180 okay so the first
one is in assumption let us assume
Johnny went to the store yesterday right
that's an assumption we can't prove it
we can't reproduce the thing now I'm
saying where it's a one-time-only thing
yeah yeah one time only can never be
applied as an axiom actually I think you
are always it's universe so it's not a
pattern is the right yeah but it's a
universal though it's a universal thing
it's Universal in the sense that
the Chinese guy in the other side of the
plan he can prove it to himself or
verify beautiful right you can't repeat
Johnny going to the having gone to the
star lines you can't do that right
that's the weird thing about action
axiom like the triangle with the 180
degrees inside yeah no matter who does
it from now on you can do it tomorrow
you do it Pat just it's not like it only
happened once and now it depends on who
you ask
but Johnny going to the store can never
be an axiom yeah an assumption can be
applied to both oh I don't like that no
no that's how can a table a triangle has
180 degrees or let's assume Johnny yeah
I think you can't say that I think that
is an axiom you can say all triangles
have you don't say let us assume all
they all have and I'll shove it down
your throat it's it's it's a little
different then it's like saying you know
again gravity you can say if I let go of
the pen it will fall to the ground it's
like a perfect axiom you can't say let
us assume it falls to the ground you
could in the sense that I don't know
what the next one's gonna do right but
if we're talking about past tense
is that what it is is it that's why we
hit it with knowledge because I'm
talking about the how do you know yeah
right and you can't do it for the few
times you can only do it with a plan
that's why it's this weird assumption
thing where you couldn't really assume
anything but an axiom is only this
pattern like repeatable thing that you
can do like do it yourself at home but
you this is I think I think we gotta go
near a teacher we knew we did another
day Lawrence yeah this is more conflicts
that we had my I hope people follow it
along because I didn't really finish my
sentences this time no no but it's okay
the the issue is we get a couple
problems
let me just synthesize or summarize here
closing arguments I'll just say that
logic is not the same thing as
rationality that's what I'm proposing
I'm proposing keeping these words
separately and I'm proposing using the
word logic for the math world and
certain things which I still have to get
in my mind computers and I want to use
the word rationality for
the world of physics and again there's a
little fine line there that I still have
not pinpointed because Alan's brought
something very important up today and
that's that you know if you punch all
this information physics information
into a computer the computer is not
gonna be you can't say oh you're a
rational computer your or your rational
you're gonna say it's just following the
logic the instructions that you fed into
it so I got to think a little bit about
these words in that context now he
raised the new context the other thing
the other thing is that the word axiom
and how that relates to assumption I
think that's a little clearer in my mind
but I think I got to think a little more
about it means what I need one more day
needs a more precise definition or like
split yeah black and white it is the one
criterion that separates wisely on work
from an assumption and it has something
to do with pattern or repeatability
maybe our viewers and Ren is watching
maybe they can get yeah
provide all the inputs you you that come
to your mind but and and then idea other
thing I want to leave you with is I
think that is a good way of confronting
people who challenge you or whom you
want to challenge tell the feed stuff
into the computer and see what the
computer spits out objectively and then
then we'll find out who who's the
rational person you or the other guy
that's a good test I think with that
I'll leave you until tomorrow same time
same station we'll see you that bye bye